je crois que ce que nous faisons ici à
Hollywood et du grand art c'est
[Applaudissements]
si tu pouvais aller n'importe où dans le
monde où est-ce que tu dirais
je veux faire partie de quelque chose de
plus grand
[Musique]
quelque chose qui dure
quand je suis arrivé à Los Angeles
interdit aux acteurs et aux chiens
j'ai changé la donne bonjour j'ai un
boulot pour toi ce que vous voulez
[Applaudissements]
je fais rien ma poitrine c'est naturel
qu'est-ce que vous diriez de le faire
maintenant mon gros plan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment envisagez-vous l'avenir il ne
faut pas faire obstacle au programme
ce sera comme ça épaulement
retournement de situation
[Musique]
cette fille a l'air mignonne elle a
aucune idée de ce qu'il attend
les modalités ont changé la morale ça
compte plus aujourd'hui
j'ai rien fait d'autre que décevoir tout
le monde tout
ma vie que mon grâce à moi pas grâce à
eux
[Musique]
tous les deux on va leur en mettre plein
la vue
ce que je fais pas de l'importance
ça nous dépasse tous
sur ce je vais me coucher
[Musique]